[Music]
okay sorry what was your name royalty
Rosie Rosie Rosie from Arizona
I'm from La Sierra somewhere cause cross
country no summer Mexico
[Music]
like 42 years old 42 small pink rat 20
years not much up all our work yes
welcome
there's a robbery sir I'm from those
barriers
well we born in another country by our
friend Sheila's Beggar's Mexico Guerrero
the ecology of communities no I ruble my
grandparents now pretty old and there
are do anything worth of work the work
while in the King's United States the
only way out of the way he was always
here not only back because there was
never money right there was nothing to
do something would be something wrong
and I was all about money and people
would slap my life
no don't ever stay in my life to come I
step one went to age of 10 years old
hmm
ten years old
foster care so you stay in foster foster
who controls 1820 well I'm doing
yeah I'm pretty home like you know my
uterus really either
yeah you're just trying everything no I
miss my room
I missed a star my eyes tell me I'm
table but how is how is your life today
how are you don't wish to take my money
hey you know did $20 you thing I kill me
$10 and say I took off with them to him
anything
so they always put my money is like an
actus Reis the devil it had money it's
always there for I did did the [ __ ]
devil it's like you don't want some
money wants a treat like my friend a
corner he'll [ __ ] me up with dimes
twenties like a crystal but he only does
it right when his first heart screeching
you are mooing first debtors couldn't
tell how much is for him and what is
that sound
yeah you know I know we have one it's a
gif appealing to know and have the
knowledge knowing that I can use like
how'd you start today how look how are
you
at the spherical give me something to
the knowledge knowing how it was
finishing what I want to go from there
so pretty much I like you so far I don't
wanna do with my mind yeah I helping
people I love people I said how could
you with Ari yes I do yes I have to do I
mean you grew up with nothing got
nothing to losing or nothing basic yes
it's an easy way but you know what it's
not always like the people who whole
thing like that
Oh Barry
people talk with big eyes and as well
got with the [ __ ] down one day okay no
gimme happy